what's going on people today i'll be
breaking down the final trailer for part
two of attack on titan the final season
which showed us some brand new content
from the upcoming episodes there's a few
small details that were easy to miss so
we are going to be talking about that
however as a warning this will involve
mentioning some spoilers if you want to
go into part 2 without knowing anything
then i'd recommend checking out my
spoiler free breakdown of the last
trailer but for this new footage there's
just no way we can talk about it without
going into spoiler territory
also i want to thank searchlightvpn for
sponsoring today's video who are
offering an 83 discount this holiday
season
for a limited time all you have to do is
go to search deals total quirk and
you'll be able to claim 83 off a two
year subscription plus four months extra
for free which works out to only 2.21 a
month i've personally been using the app
on my phone and laptop for over eight
months now and besides encrypting all my
information the interface itself is just
really clean and easy to understand
earlier this year search rock was rated
by pc mag as the best vpn for security
and it's the only major vpn that you can
use on unlimited devices for just one
subscription this insane discount is
only available for a very limited time
so click the link in the description and
use kotola quirk if you want a cheap way
to protect your online privacy today
okay so one of the first new scenes we
got from this trailer was the malian
soldiers pushing this device out of an
airship and this thing is actually the
cannon that we see peak wearing later on
this weapon is unlike any other cannon
as it's specifically designed to kill
titan shifters and the person steering
it from the inside is general magath
in this shot armin blows them up with a
thunder spear to stop magette from
firing the weapon however an interesting
thing to notice is that later on you can
see the card titan's body is destroyed
but the general is still inside the
cannon and manages to fire again
moving on there were several moments
featuring the beast titan in this
trailer and if you arrange the clips
into the correct order you realize
there's a lot of spoilers here for
example we see him show up as he throws
a bunch of rocks to destroy the malian
airships which leads to all these
burning ships crashing into the
buildings below as i just mentioned we
then get this scene of commander mcgath
firing the anti-titan cannon which then
hits zeke and causes him to fall to the
ground once on the ground the trailer
then shows us one of the beast titan's
greatest ever moments in the entire
series in my opinion and of course i'm
talking about him activating his scream
and turning every person in shiganchina
who drank the wine into a titan
unfortunately for falco he's one of the
unlucky people who did have the wine
even though it was literally just one
drop hence why there's these brief
horrifying shots of him and gabby
reacting to the scream
after this one of my favorite parts of
the trailer was aaron in his human form
running towards zeke because in the
background there's just the absolute
chaos of the scouts fighting against the
armored titan
during this scene the jaeger brothers
are desperately trying to make contact
so they can activate the power of the
founding titan while the malia military
are doing everything they can to prevent
this from happening
up until now they've tried to stop the
jaegers in various ways including rhino
fighting aaron and obviously them
shooting zeke but in this moment right
here the only thing standing in their
way is gabby's anti-titan rifle
now switching over to the past dimension
we got what is probably the clearest
look at yamir fritz in anime so far and
for those who might not know yamiya
fritz was the original founding titan
in this scene she emerges from the
coordinate and begins walking in erin's
direction as he himself is standing
directly in front of it the pars
dimension is a place that exists outside
of the normal world and in special
circumstances aldians are able to go
there which is why both jaeger brothers
are seen there together
spoiler warning ahead but the reason
they touch in this scene in the past
dimension is because zeke wants to use
the founding titan to take aaron into
their father's memories and by doing so
he's trying to prove that grisha had
brainwashed aaron in the same way he
tried to bring more zeke when he was a
child
the reason i mentioned this spoiler is
because at the beginning of the trailer
we saw a weird image of their father
almost like he'd been frozen in time and
i think these two moments are directly
related
we know from the manga that after the
jager brothers go into grisha's memories
they start observing important points
from his life and one of those important
points is when he went to confront the
royal family this scene of grisha on his
knees is almost certainly from that same
moment and i have a pretty good theory
as to why he looks like he's frozen in
time
the reason grisha is frozen is because
it's an artistic choice and it's the
anime's way of showing us how the power
of the attack titan really works
the manga showed us that aaron's attack
titan effectively gives him the power to
send memories into the past therefore
based on what we see in this trailer the
sequence could then pan out to show us
all the memories that eren has sent his
father because if you don't have that
then it will be really confusing so yeah
i feel like the anime is doing this so
that people will more easily understand
what the attack titan is capable of my
guess is there's just a visual
representation of how the attack titan
works but if you have a theory let me
know
regardless of that the final thing i
wanted to mention about this trailer is
that there were several extended shots
of aaron charging towards reiner and
these two just beating each other up and
i gotta say the cgi titans look so good
for the second half of the season like
at some point it generally becomes hard
to tell the difference between this and
the 2d animation
i should probably mention as well that
there was this brief shot of when yank
upon opening the jail cell and then
following this we see all the scouts
coming outside and the reason he did
this is because essentially number one
he's a good guy and number two they
needed to let the scouts out so that
they could help save aaron from mali
because if aaron was to be killed then
they would lose the power of the
founding titan and without that power
pretty much the entire island is going
to get wiped out the founding titan and
its power to activate the rumbling is
the only thing that can save the island
from being destroyed by the outside
world and you know regardless of whether
you're a volunteer or whether you're a
scout aaron needs to be alive like
there's just no way around it you need
to save aaron if you want to live
anyway people thank you for watching
this trailer breakdown and be sure to
sub to the channel as i'm currently
working on a new video that will explain
the complete first half of the season in
about 20 minutes or less
it will likely be out sometime this week
or the latest next week so turn on
notifications if you want to see that
until the next one peace out